you said that you learned all the
mistakes you need to learn or many of
them from your first film and that was
your film school
what were those mistakes well one of
them is a mistake I think every single
filmmaker experiences the first time
they make a movie and that was I wrote
it and I shot it and I edited it and I'm
sure as hell wasn't gonna cut that scene
because I spent time doing it the movie
I did my pure joy the first movie I did
it was a hundred and twenty minutes long
there were entire scenes that shouldn't
have even been in the film I could now
go in shave 40 minutes off that movie
that didn't need to be there they didn't
advance the plot or whatever but I fell
in love with every second of it because
I had spent time making it and I was
like it's brilliant because I made it
and it's my first film and looking back
it's like well no there's scenes where
it has nothing to do with the movie I
should have cut that entirely and
there's so much redundancies in the
dialogue that you know people go in
circles stuff like that I think it's
really important to to learn from those
mistakes and realize that everything you
do is in the the best and when you sit
down and show what you've done to a
bunch of friends who have no stake in it
and you say so what would you change and
they tell you well I'd cut these scenes
you can't just be like well I'm keeping
them anyway you have to listen to them
because at the end of the day it's
important to test screen it with people
you know and see well you know you can
shave that and shave this because they
have no stake in it then making a change
in your movie it's not like they're like
oh well because I've made that
recommendation the film will now become
a huge success and I'll get billions of
dollars no or they're like oh yes I want
to see him fail mwah-ha-ha know that
they actually genuinely want to help so
show it to your friends and family it's
better if they don't know a lot about
movies because you want to see how they
react just watching it and if you are
you know watching a movie with your
friends and they start looking at their
phone and going like this that means
it's boring if everybody goes like this
and
starts looking at their phone during the
movie that you made it's time to cut
that scene out or cut that scene down
and it's important and if you think that
it really advances the plot make sure
that if you pull it out if you pull that
scene out and then show it again do
people still know what's going on
because if they do it doesn't really
invent advance the plot I think that's
an important thing to do another
important thing that I learned is the
importance of lighting a well-lit movie
is key you have to make the movie well
lit because if it's not well lit if it's
the one of the first signs of a movie
being made by amateurs and before I was
just like well I'll just throw a light
there and I'll throw a light there and
it'll be great and then I started
realizing oh you actually there's like
3-point lighting and there's actually a
science to this and so I started
shadowing much more talented DPS than
than myself when they were working with
me and watching what they did and so
that now when I see something and how
it's lit when I'm looking at the monitor
and I don't even have you know peaking
on or anything like that I look at the
monitor and it just glows in a way where
I'm like yep that's perfectly lit let's
keep going because you can tell once you
once you're used to the way it's
supposed to look you can tell it's like
it's like the rapture happens it's like
oh you're like okay it's lit let's go
and so it's important it's important to
do that I mean it's important to know
that if it's not you could be like dosey
doe that light in here and put that over
there and maybe shift that and throw
another Kino over here and we'll be good
because at the end of the day you also
need to know how to do that and when you
start working with you know name actors
you really need to know a lot about your
lighting and you need to DP to know a
lot about your lighting because a lot of
the names you could get on lower budgets
are a bit older and you need to know how
to light actors that are aren't
teenagers and still make them look good
and it's important to know how to do
that the other thing I learned is you
can't just throw a boom up in the air
and record sound you have to have labs
and stuff sound is actually the number
one thing that somebody will look at and
be like
now I don't like this movie because if
it sounds like crap they're like well if
they didn't take the time to make it
sound good it's not it's not good so at
the end of the day distributors always
complain about sound it's the first
thing they complain about they go sound
is it well-lit blah blah
the first thing they actually really ask
is who's in it but if you have a
well-lit movie with good sound and a
good story you can get away with not
having a lot of people in it so make
sure you hone those and you know there's
also great things on YouTube like you
know Video Copilot and all these all
these different YouTube channels where
you can watch how to do little things I
spend a lot of time just sitting there
and learning these things because why
not it's it's it's great knowledge and
if you didn't know it before now you do
so always check it out
you